[Musik]
nein wir machen kein pudding was machen
wir heute einen milchshake wie heißt du
[Musik]
alles klar und der milchshake der wird
mit bananen und nutella gemacht sollten
wir mal die zutaten zeigen wo ist denn
die milch wir haben 400 milliliter milch
und wo ich das hotel drei esslöffeln
othello und wo sind die bananen und wie
viele sind das drei bananen aber wir
brauchen nur zwei stück und zwar habe
ich hier zwei ganz normale banane und
die eine ds tiefgefroren wenn ich
nämlich manchmal bananen habe die so
aussehen stecke ich sie in die
tiefkühltruhe und kannst du dann einfach
benutzen
das heißt entweder benutzen wird eine
tiefgekühlte banale oder mit ihm noch
einmal alles löffel genau dies ganz kahl
deswegen nehmen wir jetzt die
tiefgefrorene banale und eine normale
und die andere brauchen willst nicht
aber man kann auch eiswürfel benutzen
ok
kannst du von einem schönen ok-chefin
jones selbst ein messer und jetzt musste
die banane klein schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir das einfach nur noch
vermisst also schmeißt alle waren voll
wein einfach in einen mixer und jetzt
muss noch das hotel du hast es sollte
mal helfen
guck mal mit so einem spachtel geht es
nämlich viel besser guck mal da hin auch
ganz viel dran was machen wir jetzt
damit jetzt guck mal müssen wird das
alles noch vermisst dann aber die mama
machen das ist nämlich ein bisschen
gefährlich genau da kommt der deckel
drauf
das geht natürlich mit jeder anderen
mixa auch auf stufe sieben oder acht
okay jetzt fertig wollen wir mal gucken
können wir das daraus reinstecken
haltung
[Musik]